hello everyone and guess what is so
special about today yes we are going to
show an excellent chess game between
geoffrey young and levon arunyan but we
often do that but today is something
else today is the 50th anniversary of
the
well most likely the uh absolutely most
famous wheelchair championship match
that ever took place uh it is of course
the 1972 wheelchair championship match
between bobby fischer and boris posky
that took place in reykjavik iceland
so for those of you who are older
subscribers to the channel you might
remember i did a
saga on this uh
event it has some 65 videos and if you
still haven't seen it do check it out i
will put a link to it in the description
below it will be the first thing you see
so if you have time to watch 65 videos
uh it will increase your vast knowledge
greatly now that being said let's check
out this game as here uh one of the
players definitely played like a like
bobby fischer in that wheelchair
championship match so jeffree shield who
is uh i believe the youngest player in
the event i could be wrong but i'm
pretty sure he is um
uh and he's playing against the absolute
uh strongest player in the tournament
levon aaron
uh so uh you know it's gonna be great
but um uh xiong had an excellent first
day and he's the leader after the first
day so a good chance for ariana to take
some points from uh jeffrey uh we have
knights to f3 xing opens with the
diretti opening upon the d5 by lavon
sorry about that
uh
so uh d5 striking in the center we have
d4 and c5 now going for the cross
variation at c4 striking in the center
and d captures on c4 going in the
queen's gambit accepted variation the
gunsberg defense uh d5 now advancing the
pawn as uh levon's um c pawn is now
doubled here we have e6 challenging the
pawn and knight to c3 defending the pawn
with e captures queen captures and an
early queen trade queen captures knight
captures and now bishop to d6 so it
doesn't seem like anything um uh
wonderful is happening here the one has
a double c pawn and this has all been
played before but uh give it uh a few
moments with knight to d2 now going
after the c4 pawn also you cannot play
uh e4 f3 knight to c6 and now knight
captures and c4 attacking the bishop we
have bishop back to b8 again all been
played before nothing new here e4 and
now knight g to e7 by lavon now i
usually knight the d for his plate here
to
threaten knight to c to check but it's
very easy to stop this you can just put
the knight back to e3 to guard the c2
square or play bishop to d3 to guard the
c2 square so it's not that that strong
sonar gt7 by levon bishop the e3 going
after the c5 pawn and now pawn to b6
defending and preparing to develop the
light square bishop we have castles here
castle's queen side
and there is a game where bishop to b7
was played or rather um a few of them
but here levon just castles king's side
and it is now as of 12 that we have a
completely new game uh so let's see how
jeffrey deals with this with bishop to
e2
rook to e8 nicely developing once the
knight moves the e4 pawn will be
attacked so knight captures an e7 rook
captures and now how do you defend the
pawn uh well you could play something
like f3 but that's uh
not nearly as cool as what jeffrey
played he played ponte e5 and what is
this your the pawn is attacked by the
knight by the bishop by the rook so is
it a free pawn
not really and that's what makes this
position uh so awesome problem is if you
play bishop captures an e5 that's not
really going to work just knight
captures on e5 and now it doesn't matter
what you do uh if you play uh knight
captures on e5 then we just deliver rook
to d8 to check uh so you're gonna get
checkmated and then if you play rook
captures on e5 then we play bishop f3
attack the uh knight here if the knight
moves the rook hangs and if you play
bishop to b7 then we just go rook to d7
and you can resign the bishop is hanging
once you
move the bishop or defend the bishop
then the knight hangs so this is resigns
and another thing you can do instead of
capturing with the bishop let's say you
capture with the knight this is even
worse as you get checkmated right away
rook d8 check rook 8 captures this is
checkmate so here after e5 bishop to b7
by levon but now pawn to f4 and now uh
instead of having pawns on f2 and e4 you
have f4 and e5 which is just incredible
uh here we have bishop to c7 level wants
to get the other rook into the game and
now knight to d6 beautiful square for
the night and it's best
just eliminated this knight the bishop
here is singing so you have to do
something about it maybe something like
captures rook captures on d6 and now
let's say pawn to g5 even
would give black a very interesting game
however here levon tried knights to d4
he says all right you capture my bishop
i'm gonna capture your bishop with check
but now uh jeffrey's uh position is
already winning if he plays uh
everything perfectly and he does uh
bishop captures on d4 now forcing bishop
captures and e6 which is what happens
bishop back to f2 the bishop on d6 is
still hanging so bishop back to c7 and
now bishop to h4 and now both players
have the bishop pair uh the material is
equal however xiung's bishop pair is
much much stronger what do you do with
the rook if you move the rook anywhere
away from the seventh rank then rook d7
just wins the game uh for example rokita
e8 we're gonna play rogue d7 attack the
bishop and once you defend it we're
gonna play bishop to b5 and there just
isn't a good move here for uh for levon
we're going to capture the bishop rook
captures we're going to capture this
rook here and if you move the rogue
bishop p7
again this is resigns so after bishop to
h4 levon does the only thing he can and
that is to play pawn to f6 but now you
open up this diagonal so bishop to c4
with check king to f8 and now comes rook
h to f1 a beautiful move aligning the
rook with the king and the f file even
though he captures an f6 does seem to be
even stronger now the point is uh that
after bishop captures an f4 with
checklists taking to b1 uh there there's
never a good way to actually recapture
the pawn if you capture we play bishop
captures on f6 we attack the rook and
after rookie four attacking the bishop
uh now we play b3 and it's just a
terrible uh position for black the
bishops are completely cutting off uh
whoops that's not a bishop arrow the
black king rook to d7 is coming and uh
well this rook is coming to f1
game over so after king to f8 uh rook
h2f1 was played also a wonderful move uh
not the
maybe not the cleanest but it is
possible to play it uh bishop captures
on g2 and now rook to g1 this is a
beautiful move this rogue g1 because it
does seem like an automatic bishop to f2
you you attack the bishop and you keep
the rook on the f file but not so much
because after the bishop moves there's
no good way to do anything here yeah you
really want the bishop on the g file
because now after let's say e captures
black can recapture g captures and f6
which of course would be impossible if
the rook was in g-file rook g8 would be
checkmate so here okay you can play
bishop chapters but now rookie for again
we attack the bishop we don't give white
time to play rook to g1 uh but b3 and
now b5 we force the bishop to move once
the bishop moves now we can capture here
and black is back in the game so rook
the g1 absolutely essential attacking
the bishop and now one if if you move
the bishop just e captures an f6 so here
levon tries b5 uh there's really no
other good way to try and defend this
bishop captures on b5 at least you get
the bishop away from this diagonal so
you don't have to worry about getting
checkmated now comes bishop to e4 and
now bishop back to c4
so levon gave up the b5 pawn to win some
time not to get checkmated and now he
plays g5 this is um you know these are
all desperate measures but he is levon
he will try to prevail we have bishop to
f2 now going after the c5 pawn and again
no good way to defend it if you try
bishop to b6 then we just say he
captures an f6 the rook is attacked once
the rook moves we're going to play f
characters and g5 and it's uh just
absolutely unplayable again the the the
white king is completely cut off black
and completely cut off from entering the
game uh the the rooks and bishops will
will start marching forward you can play
you can even start pushing the pawn h4
h5
g6 um
you can basically play anything here and
win this with white so instead rook the
c8 was played one last attempt by levon
uh hoping that the bishop captures on c5
if maybe jeffrey will get a little bit
greedy and go after material but he
doesn't he goes for the absolute
strongest bishop to a6 just attacks the
rook and now what do you play rook c to
e8 and now only now bishop captures and
c5 we have bishop to b6 and here
even though it seems like you know
everything about the position there
might be something even better so feel
free to pause the video here and try to
find the only winning idea for jeffrey
while i give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on not falling for
lavon's mind tricks and capturing the
rook and for those of you who just want
to enjoy the show it is e captures an f6
but just because i know you guys want to
see what happens if the rook is captured
we will show it if bishop captures here
rook captures an e7 and now how do you
how do you win this uh your rook on g1
is hanging and that's that's a problem
but your even bigger problem is that
there's no way to save the rook if you
move the rook let's say rook g3 then you
allow rook c7 check and now what rook
the c3 okay we blocked check but now
bishop to e3 checked the rook here is
pinned you can't move the rook so rook
to d2 as the king has no squares the
bishop pair is now
unstoppable rook to d2 now we simply
trade everything rook captures b
captures and even bishop characters on
f4 before we win back the exchange and
that's it e captures an f6 that's a king
of seven king d1 u1 pin black captures
white captures and now king captures an
f6 and all of a sudden from a completely
winning end game you have equal material
and there is nothing to look forward to
here so a big congratulations to those
of you who decided on e captures on f6
because that is the only way to win this
game and now after you've done this now
pretty much everything is winning so
bishop captures on c5 by levon now f
captures on e7 uh with check we have
rook captures on e7 if bishop captures
an e7 then you really don't have any
problems just f captures on g5 europe
material you're up three pawns of course
completely winning for xiong uh so he
tries one last idea a levon rook
captures on e7 now the bishop still are
controlling this diagonal bishop to e3
if you can get bishop to e3 check in you
will be fine but of course xiong doesn't
allow it a
idea would be something like let's say
you play rook to g5 you grab a pawn
attack the bishop then bishop e3 and now
you resign there's nothing to do here
rook to d2 on the move now rook d7 you
pile up on the rook and now you resign
basically so here instead of this uh uh
well uh
weird idea we have rook to d8 with check
uh now comes king to f7 and now bishop
the c4 with check finally uh going after
this diagonal like we've uh
we've been doing the entire game king to
f6 and now rook to f8 with check we have
king the g7 attacking the rook and now a
spectacular finish to the game rook
captures on g5 and he was in this
position on move 34 that levon arun
resigned in the game as there is nothing
more to be done here if the rook is
accepted then rook to g8 will be
checkmate and if you don't uh again it's
not much better let's say king to h6
we're gonna capture the bishop on c5 now
we're just down too much material you're
down a full rook and you're down two
pawns and there of course is no way you
can play this
so uh really a spectacular game by
jeffrey xiong taking down lavon arenan
like that who who tried uh a tricky
opening uh he tried to you know get uh
shiong out of his comfort zone but xiong
is just playing uh incredible chess uh
one won the first the day and now
starting his second day uh well just
crushing levon aryan like this and you
know there are few players there that
are that are as creative as levon
arunian so out creating him is
definitely something to uh applaud here
uh so that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it like i said if any of you are
new to the channel or to the chess world
or you know
if you just uh you know uh wander down
the the youtube rabbit hole and are you
know
watching chess for some reason do click
on the link in the description below the
first thing you will see and experience
the incredible bobby fisher saga you
will appreciate chess much more after
after checking that out uh so yeah once
again really hope you enjoyed it i would
like to thank kalman d valer morghulis
steven abrams and nagarjuna pongotti and
david bacon for your contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this
wonderful event until it finishes uh so
thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day